*bruit stressant et de pas*
comment ça va là-bas
cher amis, il est temps de se faire une petite frayeur, d'avoir un petit peu peur il est vrai
j'espère que vous passez tous d'excellentes nuits malgré ces vidéos thread d'horreur
comment on dit en japonais
bah oui , quitte à faire plein de vidéos qui sont pareilles autant apprendre des mots
糸
voilà vous saurez
les amis aujourd'hui on va parler d'un 糸 (thread en japonais) qui est vraiment révolutionnaire
alors il est très vieux celui là mais mec il m'avais choqué sa mère quand il est sorti
en fait pour ceux qui se demandent j'ai eu une période où j'étais fasciné par le paranormal
ça me fascinait
je prenais tout mais sans , sans esprit critique
tout ce qu'on me disait je le croyais , je disais : ouais un fantôme ? wow. il a fait volé ton bol à travers la pièce ouais
j'étais vraiment crédule comme on dit
mais aujourd'hui c'est fini , regardez la preuve
le mec refuse d'évoluer sur ça , c'est incroyable
il s'agit d'un thread , non pas sur twitter mais sur reddit
pour ceux qui connaissent pas reddit c'est un site extrêmement cool on peut parler de truc qu'on aime on peut voter pour ce qui est mieux , fin bref
pire résumé de reddit mais,
Oui, vous allez là dessus
et ça marche bien aussi
Alors j'espère que tout le monde n'a pas suivi
ce truc là à l'époque sinon la vidéo sert à rien, ou au pire on va le revivre ensemble.
Moi là je viens là je viens de le relire et je l'ai
revécu le truc, vraiment comme la première fois que je l'ai lu,
c'est génial. Aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter l'histoire d'un type qui s’appelle Nathan et qui a publié
il y a trois ans, un gros thread sur reddit.
Nathan commence son thread en disant qu'il vient de recevoir un autre message.
On sait pas de quoi il parle,
que ce message là est pire que les autres et que là,
il à besoin de catalyser tous cela dans un thread .
Mais de quoi parle-t-il? Nathan nous explique que sa copine est morte
le 7 Août 2012 , dans un accident de voiture
alors qu'elle revenait du travail. Plus précisément,
il y a une voiture qui a grillé un feu rouge à un carrefour
et qui est rentrée dans la voiture de sa copine et sa copine
est décédée dans les minutes qui ont suivi l'accident
c'est tragique. Nathan nous dit qu'au moment de l'accident ça faisait presque
cinq ans, qu'ils étaient ensemble, que lui,
il pensait à se marier avec elle. Mais elle, elle était pas très chaude, c'était pas trop son délire
Mais Nathan nous dit que si le mariage c'était son délire,
il l'aurait épousée au bout de trois mois de relation
Il était fou amoureux d'elle. Nathan prend le temps de nous dire que,
que c'était une fille géniale, qu'elle aimait toucher à tout,
qu'elle adorait aussi bien le camping,
que la technologie, qu'elle à toujours sentait la cannelle.
Ah, Il donne plein de détails comme ça mais en fait,
il nous dit qu'il a besoin de nous décrire
la personne formidable, qu'elle était avant de décrire autre chose,
de beaucoup plus bizarre et
étrange.  Et ça aura son importance plus tard, donc écoutez bien.
4 Septembre 2013
C'est la où le cauchemar commence pour Nathan.
Nathan a pris soin de laisser le compte
d'Emily
ouvert, comme si elle était encore vivante, pour
pouvoir se balader dans ses albums .
Aller écrire un petit message sur son mur. Bref, tout ce qui peut lui
rappeler sa
bien aimée et lui faire
du bien
voilà chacun sa manière
de faire son deuil et d'essayer d'aller mieux.
On jugera pas! Je sais pas si je l'ai dit, mais sa copine ,
elle s'appelait Emily, voilà, si jamais. Je suis une m**de.
Nathan nous dit qu'il avait donné le mot
de passe du compte facebook de
Emily à la maman d'Emily
qui s'appelle Suzan
Il précise qu'elle va zéro sur l'ordi, qu'elle a dû passer 3 minutes sur Facebook sans rien comprendre à ce qui se passait
Mais bon voila si jamais elle avait besoin comme Nathan d'aller voir ses photos ses messages tout ça elle pouvait le faire
Alors qu'est ce qui passé le 4 p***n de septembre 2013 Lucas ?
Et bah Emile elle a envoyé 1 message à Nathan
Et oui
C'est pas terrifiant mec, on voit 1 morceau de conversation au dessus, ça c'est des messages qu'il lui a envoyé juste quand il avait besoin de lui parler comme si elle était encore là, et là Emily répond bonjour
Bruit sinistre
Ho p***n
Ce à quoi Nathan répond:"Suzan vous êtes sur le compte d'Emilie
il a filé le compte a suzan , la maman d'émilie
il se dit que c'est sûrement elle et qu'elle a oublié de  se déco et de se remettre sur son compte , elle connait pas trop la technologie
et il a raison, il rationalise il a raison
mais ce qu'il sait pas c'est que c'est peut-être vraiment émilie !
ok on continue et la je sais que la vous commencez à vous dire : Ha ! ça commence à être intéressant cette histoire
Nathan se précipite alors sur son téléphone pour appeler suzanne et lui demander si c'est elle qui s'est connecté au compte de sa fille
et suzanne lui dit qu'elle ne s'y est pas connecté depuis la semaine où sa fille est décédée
c'est chaud mec
Nathan se dit alors qu'elle connaissait beaucoup de monde et que c'est surement l'un de ces pseudo-amis
qui connait un peu le game de la technologie et qui a récupéré son mot de passe
qui veut juste le baiser de la pire façon et lui faire du mal pour rien
le 16 novembre donc 2 mois après le premier message
émilie lui envoie un nouveau message
allons se ballader sur le sentier *** ce dimanche
Nathan a pris soin de flouter le sentier en question pour pas que les gens y aille ou qu'ils retrouvent là où ils habitent , bref il a raison il se protège
et en voyant ça Nathan il a remarqué un truc c'est que c'est des messages que émilie a vraiment envoyé de son vivant , des mois auparavant
il se rend compte que en gros l'usurpateur d'identité qui est sur ce putain de compte il s'amuse à remonter la conversation
et à remettre des messages qu'elle a vraiment envoyé de son vivant à Nathan
C'est horrible !
Nathan répond alors : bon bordel t'es qui ?
ce à quoi émilie répond : les roues du bus
Ce message est chelou mais Nathan nous précise que enfaite sa viens d'une discussion qui a eu entre lui et Émilie beaucoup plus tôt
quand ils étaient entrain de planifier un road trip qui n'a jamais eu lieu parce qu'elle est décédée avant malheureusement
et en gros ils s'envoyaient des musiques à télécharger pour les mettre dans la voiture pendant le road trip
Nathan demande alors à la "fausse" émilie de dire qui s'est qui fait ça
et la personne en face ne répond pas pendant plusieurs mois
vous imaginez ? il y a quelqu'un tout les 2 mois qui t'envoie un ou deux messages avec le compte d'une personne qui est décédée et que t'apprécie énormement
et tu sais pas qui c'est
3 mois plus tard en février 2014
Nathan il va sur facebook et qu'est ce qu'il voit ?
IL voit que émilie s'est tagué sur des photos de lui
et en arrivant sur la photo il s'aperçoit que le tague est la où elle se trouvait quand elle était encore vivante et qu'ils étaient ensemble a l'appartement même
donc c'est hyper glauque et la Nathan il se dit putain qu'est ce que c'est cette merde là ça devient vraiment glauque
la on est plus sur une simple blague de quelqu’un qui se connecte sur le compte de la personne pour t'envoyer des messages ce qui est deja très très chaud